welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and black panther wakanda forever
was originally going to open with
Chadwick Boseman t'challa undusting
after the blip just to find his wife
with another man Nakia you let him get
you hey this is according to director
Ryan coogler and co-writer Joe Robert
Cole to your New York Times who
confirmed that before Chadwick Boseman
passed away they're much speculated
about 2020 draft of the Black Panther 2
script focused largely on t'challa in
Tucson AKA t'challa Jr as a father and
son plot after t'challa returned from a
forced five-year absence remember back
in November I actually conducted an
investigation into various interviews
before and after the movie released and
concluded based on statements from
Kugler that his original script must
have focused on the theme of fathers
forcibly separated from their families
and returning after those absences and
so yeah it's pretty validating to hear
coogler confirm this and offer so
transparency into his writing process
which is a Really Brave move that not
all creatives who work on these titles
are willing to do so in this video I'm
going to break down the alternate
opening scene to Black Panther 2 the
full plotline for this movie that they
had to let go of and how this would have
affected not just the sequel but the MCU
Beyond it so on December 23rd Ryan
coogler and Joe Robert Cole finally
opened up to the New York Times about
their original plan for black panther 2.
coogler said and I'm gonna read the
whole quote here because every bit of it
is fascinating it was what are we going
to do about the blip that was the
challenge it was absolutely nothing like
what we made it was going to be a
father-son story from the perspective of
a father because the first movie had
been a father-son story from the
perspective of the suns in the script
t'challa was a dad who had had this
forced five-year absence from his son's
life the first scene was an animated
sequence you hear Nakia talking to
Tucson she says tell me what you know
about your father you realize that he
doesn't know his dad was the Black
Panther he's never met him and Ikea is
remarried to a Haitian dude then we cut
to reality and it's the night that
everybody comes back from the blip you
see t'challa meet the kid for the first
time then it catch ahead three years and
he's essentially co-parenting we had
some crazy scenes in there for Chad man
our code name for the movie was summer
break and the movie was about a summer
that the kid spends with his dad for his
eighth birthday they do a ritual where
they go out into the bush and have to
live off the land but something happens
and t'challa has to go to save the world
with his son on his hip that was the
movie wow so much to unpack there now
what coogler and Cole eventually settled
on for the rewrites opening scene of
shuri in the lab praying to boss trying
to save her brother was incredible so
nothing against that at all but this
just proves that these two wrote two
amazing opening sequences for this movie
some of my favorite scenes in Marvel
phase 4 have been what I call blip
fiction the little vignettes showing
each character at the time of the blip
as it ended which ranged from tragic
with Monica Rambo and Wanda Vision to
disorienting with Elena Bulova and
Hawkeye to comedic with that tuba player
in Spider-Man far from home but this
removed black panther 2 intro sounds
like it would have been the best of
these the night everyone returns in the
blip literally the moments before during
and immediately after t'challa join in
The Avengers in the Battle of Earth and
in game including after t'challa took a
knee to mourn Tony Stark and that
in-game deleted scene that I consider
Canon because why not but presumably
before t'challa attended Tony's funeral
back on his farm Ryan coogler didn't
specify if t'challa would have met
Toussaint before Wong met up with him to
open a portal to the rebel of Avengers
compound remember Dr Strange assigned
Wong to gather everyone is that everyone
what you wanted more or if t'challa
could have met up with Nakia and Tucson
afterwards after the dust settled from
the battle I'm gonna guess it was after
the battle but there wouldn't have been
that much time between Hulk snapping
everyone back and those returners
portaling into the battle and think
about it if Nakia had resettled in Haiti
the child would have needed quite a bit
of time to go track her down now I'm on
camera a lot so I have to see my face a
lot so you think I would have to put a
lot of effort in my skincare routine but
you know what I really don't because I
use geology geology is a 15 time
award-winning personalized skincare
company recognized in hypebe's birdie
Men's Health and Esquire and Aspen
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews and they've recently expanded to
offer products for or pretty much
whatever you need all you got to do is
take this 30 second diagnostic quiz and
geology is going to figure out your
routine for you like if you need some
hair care well use geology's co-wash
it's a specially formulated cream
cleanser that removes buildup and
cleanses the hair without the big lather
the harsh ingredients of typical shampoo
and for the rest of your shower routine
you can use their body washes they're
free of harsh ingredients they smell
great and are refillable and for after
the shower protect your skin from
environmental stressors with vitamin C
plus e for Relic serum to keep your skin
looking young and healthy and then a bit
of dermatologist tested aluminum free
deodorant that really smells great right
now for a limited time geologists
hooking our audience up with an
absolutely crazy offer use the code new
rockstars they will give you an
additional 70 off their award-winning
skincare trial set that discount applies
whether you're stocking up for yourself
or stuffing someone else's stocking
instead either way geology has you
covered check out their awesome gift
sets featuring all of your favorite
geology products to get started just
click the link in the description take a
30 second diagnostic quiz and their team
of dermatologists will design a
personalized routine just for you that
ships directly to your door but actually
this scene would have come after this
animated opening that Google described
which I'm guessing was referring to the
beautiful grains of sand sequence that
opened the 2018 film remember in that
movie it was t'chata's brother in jobu
telling a bedtime story to Young
injadaka killmonger about the origins of
wakanda this sick will would have
paralleled that but with a heartbreaking
reveal that t'challa's son does not
really know that much about him at least
doesn't know the truth of his heroics or
sacrifices this is a theme that Ryan
coogler has been so good at exploring as
a filmmaker with movies like Creed and
Fruitvale Station what happens when
fathers are taken away from their sons
what happens to the fathers and more
importantly what happens to the sons
coogler when asked by the times about
Neymar as the villain confirms that
Neymar was always in the movie but that
the original plan was for it to be a
three-way conflict between wakanda the
United States and telecon but quote it
was all mostly from the child's
perspective it's also interesting to
hear about this summer break scenario
where Toussaint spends part of the year
in Haiti but a summer in wakanda and
going through this rite of passage
having to go into the bush to live off
the land sounds like a mix of Spartan
youth training but something unique to
wakanda some something t'challa must
have done with his father we're actually
reminded of t'challa around that same
age shown in the opening of what if
Episode 2 had to Chaka taken t'challa on
that survival trip yet is that why
t'challa took off on his own went
outside the board of wakanda and in this
what if hypothetical got abducted by
yondu these kinds of traditions and
rituals of wakanda is something that I
wish we had more of in the theatrical
version of wakanda forever like the
funeral sequence is obviously super
meaningful and beautifully shot but it
was kind of hard to focus on anything
other than having to say goodbye to
t'challa I just would have loved what
the Boy Scout looked like also in this
original opening t'challa would have
been emblematic of the social disruption
caused by people suddenly returning from
the blip blip fiction yup my mind goes
to this Haitian dude that Kugler
mentioned yikes to be a stepdad
competing with the Black Panther I mean
I was gonna Fan cast Mt in this role but
I wouldn't want to ask our guy to shoot
himself let me know your thoughts on
this alternate opening scene in the
comments below you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at avos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you